let's just quickly read the question to
go up Marysol ends that amount of money
per hour again you can see that per
which gives you the clue of where the
break is as a publicist how much will
she earn if she works that long in one
week okay so I've written it down you've
identified your units which are what are
the units again yep perfect okay so
there they are included and then I've
written them down in the equation but
the last area desired is well what
operation is going to combine this
together some suggestions okay so if I
put multiplication in here right that's
a good suggestion you can think I want
to have groups of these 38 groups of
them that's a modification there's
another clue the units which helps us to
work out why multiplication works what's
the final unit that we want in the
answer have a look carefully let's see
if I get someone else look at the
question and what final unit should be
included Annika it should be dollars
because says how much has she earned so
I want this unit to hang around and I
want this unit to weigh okay so
therefore I don't know if you've written
it like this which shows the extra
working this is an hour on the bottom of
the fraction and this is the same unit
on the top of the fraction right so if I
use multiplication then I can cancel
cancel and can someone tell me what the
value is there's someone already
calculated it yeah well 893 exactly okay
there you go so the units confirm right
now the last one is a bit tricky I'm
going all the way to question 12 let's
do it together if you're not up to it
already
read with me it says a bus is traveling
at an average speed of 76 km/h so right
away you can tell me the units are what
are the units someone has to say you can
get
someone who hasn't said yeah Darren
kilometers/hour school this is not hard
right but it's the most important first
step
I've got my units how long will the bus
take to travel three hundred and eighty
kilometers
okay now three hundred and eighty
Columbus is how far we have to go
seventy-six right 76 km/h is how fast we
travel what operation should I include
between these okay I'm gonna do division
okay a division does make sense because
it's like look this is some number of
groups of 76 calls per hour it's like
every hour I'm gonna do one of these so
there's a whole bunch of groups of 76 in
there that I want to find okay the other
way that I can know is watch this right
you know this extra line here as we
write as a fraction just do it with me
if you haven't already how can I write
this guy to make it a little more
obvious that it's a fraction this
doesn't look like a fraction but how can
i rewrite it yeah okay I've got the 76
over 1 but don't forget I want to what
was the third tip again yeah I want to
include the unit's right those are like
super important okay now have a look at
this right when you divide by a fraction
think back all the way to the side of
you what do you do when you divide by a
fraction you pause pause think that's a
yes 3 divided by 1/4 what you do with
this what you do yeah
okay you can ride in a straight line
that's fine that's fine but then what I
do it this guy over here if I change it
to 4 over 1 then this change to
multiplication right because these are
opposites right and I can do just the
same thing here watch right I'm gonna
have three eighty kilometers I'm going
to change this to multiplication so as a
consequence I write this as one hour
over good and look what's happened to
the unit's look look look you see cancel
cancel what unit is left behind hours is
that what I was after I was after a time
wasn't it said how long that's a time
question right so I've got the right
unit all I have to do is three hundred
and eighty divided by 76 which is okay
so identify the units our shoes
carefully which operation you're going
to use and then make sure you include
all that in the work and you saw how
much I refer to that okay